[Music]
hey everyone i'm scarlett johansson and
i'm florence pugh i'm david harbor we
are the cast of marvel studios black
widow which is all about family we're
here to share some family values you can
find in our new movie make sure to
express gratitude for each other i
couldn't be more proud of you you smell
really bad be supportive of one another
good spots honey meals are an important
bonding time for the family natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get the bag hunched listen to
your mother talk things out and make
sure to listen to each other
always pick each other up when they're
down you okay great plan i love the part
where i almost bled to death that's what
families are for
we are very excited to be finally
premiering black widow it's a movie
that's been three years i think in the
making really decade plus in the making
in some ways it's about family and about
self-forgiveness it's unexpected in a
lot of ways but certainly you can expect
all the explosive action that one comes
to when watching a marvel movie and you
get to watch the superhero family bicker
the entire way through
i think
chef's kiss the action in this movie
i've never seen anything like it it's
incredible and then it has a real heart
to it which is about family and about
human beings and about redemption you're
gonna
have a good time check out black widow
in theaters or stream on disney plus
with premiere access on july 9.
you